pas ce président bonjour nom d'arlette
chabot et moi même soir bercy nous
accueillir donc au nom de france 2
france 24 tv5 europe et de tf1 il ya eu
beaucoup d'annoncés ces derniers jours
de nombreux chantiers ouverts parfois de
quoi donner un peu le tournis aux
syndicats et aux formations politiques
mais j'imagine que les français ont
surtout envie d'entendre des choses
extrêmement concrète de leur part et
nous allons essayer avec arlette de
relayer leurs questions alors tout
d'abord sur les régimes spéciaux que
vous avez abordé hier ces régimes
spéciaux de retraite
d'abord quel calendrier vous donner et
puis est-ce que vous allez tenir compte
de la spécificité et de la pénibilité de
certains de ces régions écoutez moi j'ai
été élu par les français pour trouver
des solutions aux problèmes de la france
on m'a pas élu pour commenter les
problèmes de la france
on m'a élu pour trouver des solutions à
des problèmes qui sont pendants depuis
des années et parmi ces problèmes il ya
la question du financement de nos
origines de retraite les français
veulent être assurés que leurs retraites
seront financées qui pourront partir à
la retraite
alors il ya des décisions qui n'ont pas
été prises toutes ces années passées
mais il faut les prendre tranquillement
simplement
c'est le cas de ce qu'on appelle les
régimes spéciaux les cheminots les
agents de la ratp les gaziers et
électriciens
je veux dire deux choses aux français
d'abord il faut pas stigmatiser ces
catégories de français
ils sont pas coupables et une raison
quand même pour lequel non mais il ya un
régal d'abord il ya la pénibilité de
leur travail
ensuite ya l'histoire des luttes
sociales dans notre pays ça compte
et lorsqu'ils ont été embauchés la ratp
edf à gaz de france a la sncf ils ont
trouvé un régime
il s'agit un statut il s'agit donc pas
de les accuser de quoi que ce soit pour
comme un des privilégiés comme dit
certain à pour moi non on n'est pas
privilégiée parce que c'est les petits
salaires
ils sont des blocs sont difficiles il
veut d'ailleurs dire une chose c'est que
j'ai pas oublier l'attitude de ses
fonctionnaires
lors de la tempête de 1999 on était bien
content de les trouver
les électriciens lorsque tout s'est
effondré et j'ai pas oublier le courage
des agents de la ratp
lorsqu'il ya eu les émeutes de 2005 et
qu'il fallait pour aller chercher les
gens domicile pour la leur travail
conduire les bus dans des quartiers où
il y avait des émeutiers donc ce sont
des femmes et des hommes que je respecte
qui ne doivent pas être accusés parce
qu'ils ont hérité d'un système d'un
statut mais il se trouve qu'un problème
majeur dans notre pays c'est que tous
les salariés du privé doivent cotiser 40
n est point avant leur retraite depuis
1981 14
monsieur balladur tous les salariés du
public doivent cotiser 40 ans pour avoir
leur retraite
c'est la réforme qui engage et jean
pierre raffarin avec françois fillon et
les seuls sur lesquels il n'y avait pas
eu cet effort de fait ce sont les
régimes spéciaux ils ont à prendre cet
ennemi à peu près qui sont à 37 et demi
et je propose de les aligner sur le
régime général de la fonction publique
et chacun doit comprendre qu'il n'ya
aucune raison qu'un métallos qu'un
ouvrier du textile ou qu'un salarié du
privé cotisent 40 années quand les
autres cotisent 30 cette année et avant
combien de temps et allemand alors ça
c'est on va renégocier de ça donc ça
c'est le principe
et je le dis je ne céderai pas sur ce
principe parce que c'est un principe
d'équité on peut pas dire à des millions
de français
vous devez cotisé 40 ans il ya quelques
millions d'autres vous devez cotiser
quand cette année et demie même si on
doit tenir compte de la pénibilité
alors même s'il ya du monde dans la rue
même s'il ya des grèves et qui est des
grèves c'est un droit constitutionnel
propre échelle et jean-pierre grève mais
moi je veux essayer de faire des choses
de la façon la plus juste
je leur dis donc ces catégories de
français
premièrement votre statut particulier
vous le conserverai deuxièmement le
gouvernement est prêt à discuter assez
largement du temps qu'il faut pour
arriver aux quarante années par exemple
pour le régime général de la fonction
publique
il avait été indiqué qu'il fallait cinq
ans on peut en discuter de tout cela
ce don
sur le coup on ne peut pas transiger
c'est le principe d'égalité d'équité
tout le monde doit cotiser 40 voilà
alors je le dis très simplement très
calmement je le dis en en ayant
parfaitement conscience de l'effort
qu'on leur demande de la difficulté que
c'est un pilote support da fort si
c'était facile les autres gouvernements
leurs effets s'ils n'ont pas fait
c'était compliqué moi je parie à 101,95
ce dernier à une tentative ça s'est mal
passé ce concours c'est que cette fois
les esprits sont davantage ouverts prêts
à accepter que ce soit d'ailleurs
l'opinion publique semble assez prête
selon les enquêtes d'opinion voir ceux
qui bénéficient de ce régime oui mais
non je ne veux pas monter une partie de
l'opinion contre eux parce que ça serait
injuste jeudi aux cheminots aux agents
de la ratp ou gaziers aux électriciens
ya tous les autres que je fais confiance
à leur honnêteté on leur garantit le
respect de leur statut particulier mais
ils doivent comprendre qu'il peut pas y
avoir pour les français deux catégories
de français ceux qui cotisent 40 années
et ce qu'ils kossity 30 cette année
voilà la négociation souffre elle va
s'ouvrir au niveau confédéral xavier
bertrand avec la coordination
naturellement du premier ministre
françois fillon engage les discussions a
déjà commencé et je souhaite que très
rapidement sa part entreprise par
entreprise pour tenir compte de la
spécificité des statuts et de la
pénibilité des métiers pour la grêle de
l'association la fin d'année bien sûr à
la fin de l'année mais écoutez arlette
chabot ça fait 20 ans qu'on parle de
tout ça ça fait 20 ans tous les
gouvernements regardent ce problème et
le laisse de côté tranquillement les
français l'ont élu pour trouver des
solutions
je trouverai des solutions j'ajoute que
parce qu'on aura fait cela on pourra dès
poser la question difficile de
l'amélioration des petites retraites
il ya quand même trois millions de
retraités qui sont en dessous du minimum
vieillesse ce n'est pas admissible est
la question qu en plus difficile des
pensions de réversion c'est à dire des
veuves qui se retrouve avec 52% d'une
petite retraite
ça fait pas grand chose donc j'essaie de
conduire une politique jeu
et je pense que j'ai ce que j'ai proposé
aux organisations syndicales
c'est juste les trouve que le calendrier
sera difficile à tenir pour eux ça leur
paraît c'est même impossible impossible
s'il s'agit d'eau met quelques semaines
de plus ce bébé sûr qu'on les mettra
mais il ya quelque chose qu'il faut bien
qu'on comprenne je ne transigerai pas
sur la sphère des 37 à des mythes
cotisations qui doit passer à 40
nous négocierons tant qu'il le faut sur
le temps pour y arriver sur les statuts
particuliers sur la pénibilité
je n'accepterai pas qu'on désigne
catégories de fonctionnaires comme étant
coupable sont coupables de rien le
cheminots de la sncf
quand il a été embauché par un gros
salaire et puis a trouvé ce statut
s'agit pas d'accuser personnes il s'agit
de trouver les moyens de financer un
régime qui a besoin qu'on travaille plus
longtemps pour pouvoir être financés
pour les comme on vit plus longtemps si
on cotise pas plus longtemps c'est pas
possible de le filon pour la grève est
d'ores et déjà annoncés dans un mois
tout juste vous allez mettre en place ce
fameux service minimum que vous alliez
annoncé pendant la bien sûr il ya une
loi elle doit s'appliquer
la grève va écouter s'il ya des
problèmes dans les affrontera mais enfin
moi j'ai été élu et vous savez j'ai dit
une chose c'est pendant toute la
campagne j'ai pas mentir j'ai dit que la
question des régimes spéciaux de
retraite se poser personne ne peut dire
qu'il est pris en traître personne ne
peut dire que c'est un engagement que je
n'ai pas tenus je suis en train de tenir
un engagement que j'ai pris
c'était pas facile j'ai dit avant
l'élection à tous les titulaires
d'origine spéciaux coûté si je suis élu
président de la république vous
cotiseraient 40 années comme tous les
autres français pas plus mais pas moins
gelé dit avant l'élection qui pourrait
comprendre qu'après l'élection je ne
fasse plus mais plus généralement pour
les autres fonctionnaires vous avez dit
oui on avait dit fière d'être formidable
mais votre statut est obsolète ce que
vous pensez que ce pays est rouillée et
qu' il est victime de trop dit moby
c'est là aussi oui je pense profondément
que les fonctionnaires sont formidables
et qu'on n'en parle pas bien des
fonctionnaires je n'aime pas la façon
dont on parle des fonctionnaires
d'autres pays on oppose les uns aux
autres c'est pas ma conception de la
nation
et là encore je voudrais qu'on arrête de
parler des statuts mais catégorie et
qu'on parle des femmes et des hommes
je voudrais prendre des exemples il n'y
a pas de mobilité dans la fonction
publique
quand votre mari nous votre épouse un
nouveau poste vous pouvez pas passer de
la fonction territoriale à le fonction
d'étain vous pouvez pas changer de
métier il n'y a pas de formation
continue il ya la maladie des concours
et des examens pour progresser alors
prenez la mère de famille de 42 ans qui
a deux enfants qui travaille toute la
journée pour progresser doit passer des
concours d examen extrêmement difficile
moi je dis le mérite
la valorisation l'expérience ça compte
on va leur donner un coup de main elle
va améliorer la qualité du travail à
l'ère numérique par exemple bien a dit
un prof comme on évalue une mérites d'un
prof ah bon ils ont coûté dans tous les
français savent bien que dans les écoles
il ya la maîtresse ou le professeur que
tout le monde réclame parce qu' il est
celui dont on sait parfaitement qu'il
donne encore plus aux enfants
moi je dis pas qu'il faut enlever à qui
que ce soit qui fait juste son travail
mais il n'est pas normal qu'on
reconnaisse la performance dans le
secteur public comme dans les autres
je voudrais qu'on arrête un enseignant
qui veut aller emmené sa classe au
théâtre faire une sortie montrer la
nature à ses élèves
c'est une débauche d'énergie
considérable pour prendre une initiative
de moi je veux qu'ils soient valorisés
je souhaite que dans chaque
établissement d'un minimum d'autonomie
que les enseignants ne soit plus notée
sur leur capacité à appliquer la
dernière circulaire du dernier ministre
mais sur leurs moyens passionné m ah oui
ça certainement moins de circulaires sur
leurs capacités à apprendre à lire
écrire compter à nos enfants
je veux poser la question de la qualité
du travail des fonctionnaires y compris
de leur rémunération d'un quart des
réserves supplémentaires mais quelque
chose que j'ai appris
extraordinaire savez vous que dans la
fonction publique les heures
supplémentaires sont moins bien payés
que les heures normales et qu'il est des
secteurs on n'a même pas le droit de
faire des heures supplémentaires des
quoi prenez l'exemple d'une mairie après
tout c'est pas absurde que les services
publics sont ouverts le samedi
jean sont disponibles pour aller dans
les services publics eh bien je souhaite
qu'un fonctionnaire qui fasse des heures
supplémentaires soient payés sur ces
heures supplémentaires
regardez à l'hôpital c'est inadmissible
qui s'est passé des dizaines de milliers
d'heures supplémentaires qui ne sont pas
payés aux infirmières aux agents
hospitaliers
il faut régler ce problème alors comment
va le régler soit en permettant de
transformer du temps libre que les gens
ne peuvent pas prendre un pouvoir
d'achat soit en permettant de
transformer ce temps libre en années de
cotisation retraite mais je veux que
tous ceux qui ont travaillé plus est une
rémunération de ce travail
supplémentaire questions sur le pécule
parce que vous allez proposer un petit
pécule pour des fonctionnaires qui
auraient envie de partir changer fait
d'aller dans le trade est certainement
vécu ça assez mal quoi ah bon pourquoi
je suis pas quelqu'un qui fonctionne
depuis 20 ans puis qui souhaitent avoir
une autre activité pour qu'on lui
permettrait pas de la voir une seconde
vie un second choix
au nom de quoi on doit tout figé tout
bloquer tout le statufier mais notre
société en meurent de tout cela il faut
augmenter la possibilité de choisir
j'ai dit également aux hauts
fonctionnaires de france manche m'étais
engagé j c'est un engagement que j'ai
pris et on peut pas continuer en bouche
et parce que la france vit au dessus de
ses moyens on à 1200 milliards de dette
les salaires et les retraites c'est 45 %
du budget de la france
si on remplace tout le monde qui part à
la retraite on pourra pas réduire les
déficits et nous allons proposer avec le
premier ministre que la moitié des
économies réalisées en gains de
productivité ont leur redonneraient en
pouvoir d'achat aux fonctionnaires moins
de fonctionnaires mieux payés
c'est sa fonction publique moderne si
nous ne remplaçons pas pendant cinq ans
un fonctionnaire sur deux qui part à la
retraite
on reviendra au niveau de la fonction
publique de 1992 monsieur mitterrand
était président de la république je ne
sache pas ma connaissance comme 1992 la
france était sous administrée alors
puisqu'on parle mais 35 heures que d'une
prise les guerres pourquoi vous les
supprimez pas carrément puisque
il ya toujours des toilettages d'énièmes
version alors sur les 35 heures ont été
d'abord nous sommes le seul pays au
monde à nous est doté de cette
législation
y'en a pas un autre et on l'a payé de
deux problèmes plus de chômeurs que les
autres parce qu'un pays qui travaillent
moins que les autres c'est un pays qui
créent moins de richesses et qui avons
une croissance et toute ma stratégie
économique c'est de libérer les forces
de travail dans notre pays pour gagner
ce point croissance qui nous manque
et puis on l'a payé d'un deuxième
problème qui est immense en france c'est
qu'on ne parle plus des salaires on ne
parle plus du pouvoir d'achat il en
parle du temps les mois je m'inscris en
faux contre ceux qui disent je sois
disant experts qu'il n'y a pas de
problème de pouvoir d'achat en france il
y a gigantesque problème de pouvoir
d'achat
comment résoudre en permettant aux gens
de travailler plus pour gagner plus
heures qu'est ce qu'on va faire
d'abord à partir du 1er octobre toutes
les heures supplémentaires que feront
les salariés français ils ne paieront
pas d'impôts et paieront pas de charge
dessus donc on encourage les entreprises
à donner 10 ans supplémentaires et on
encourage les salariés à faire des
heures supplémentaires
imaginez ce qu'on dirait de -6 jeux
proposés aux français de gagner plus
sans travailler plus dur il le fabrique
cet argent comment il fait deuxième
élément je me faciliter la possibilité
pour les salariés de choisir entre du
temps libre ou du pouvoir d'achat il ya
des tas de salariés qui ont des
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat et qui
veulent pouvoir transformer les jours de
congés accumulés parce qu'ils ont fait
des heures supplémentaires en pouvoir
d'achat en salaires aux rémunérations
on va les autoriser et enfin je voudrais
que les heures choisi ce soit la liberté
du salarié savez vous qu'un salarié
français n'a pas le droit de faire des
heures supplémentaires dans son
entreprise s'il n'y a pas eu un accord
pour la branche
c'est hallucinant il faut laisser un
accord d'entreprise
il faut laisser les gens discuter les
100 galeries en entreprise mais pourquoi
empêcher mais enfin c'est quand même
l'idée très curieuse que celle qui
consiste à vouloir empêcher absolument
les gens ne travaillait plus pour gagner
davantage
et comment vous est aussi pousser les
entreprises quand même augmenter les
salaires vous aviez lancé un petit appel
aux chefs d'entreprise lorsque vous êtes
allés au medef
vous négociez et augmenter les salaires
humana le chabot moi je suis chef de
l'état je dois être juste et je dis aux
chefs d'entreprise que je n'accepte pas
la situation selon laquelle une fois par
an les conseils d'administration se
réunissent pour débattre de la
rémunération comprenez l'augmentation de
la rémunération du gérant et dans la
même entreprise
après avoir augmenté le dirigeant on
explique pour les salariés qui a plus de
pouvoir d'achat et qu'on peut pas les
augmenter la loi prévoit des
négociations c'est rien donc je dis les
choses extrêmement clairement dans les
entreprises où il n'y aura pas de
négociation salariale et où on laissera
le salaire minimum en dessous du smic
les minima de branche en dessous du smic
on posera la question des allégements de
charges les allègements de charges on ne
donnera pas lorsqu'il n'y aura pas de
discussion salariale dans l'entreprise
alors vous donner plus de pouvoir
d'achat est au fond et il n'est pas
pauvre mais en même temps d'une autre
main vous préparer là pour je vois le
débat beaucoup de gens qui disent mais
c'est la compétitivité des entreprises
qui comptent comme si le fait qu'un
salarié qui va au travail en disant
qu'il est exploité c'est pas un problème
pour la compétitivité de l'entreprise
une entreprise c'est le dirigeant et
c'est le dernier les salariés c'est une
communauté de femmes et d'hommes et la
question du pouvoir d'achat
elle se pose je vais d'ailleurs aller
beaucoup plus loin en réformant
complètement cette loi si compliqué
qu'on appelle la loi galland qui
interdit tenez vous bien aux
distributeurs aux grandes surfaces de
redonner aux consommateurs les
ristournes la musardière des
fournisseurs ou alors que personne n'y
comprend rien
c'est extrêmement compliqué mais les
grandes surfaces prises tu sais pas
voilà offert les grandes surfaces
discute avec les fournisseurs obtiennent
des ristournes et ses ristournes ne les
retrouve pas chez le consommateur qui
voit bien que depuis l'euro les prix ont
augmenté
je souhaite que les prix baissent et
donc on va libérer les possibilités
négociations entre fournisseurs et
distributeurs grandes surfaces je dis
tout de suite d'ailleurs que pour les
prix agricoles
je ferai une exception parce que je
considère que les prix en matière
agricole et alimentaire de san jose
fabrique pas de la même façon
que pour les grandes marques que je ne
citerai pas parce que je n'ai pas leur
faire de publicité alors dans le même
temps vous avez quand même prévu la
franchise médicale ce qui est un
problème aussi pour le pouvoir d'achat
des gens et ça veut dire aussi que ça va
les pousser à avoir des assurances
privées et peut-être à aller vers une
médecine à deux vitesses est une affaire
compliquée policiers d'emprise
simplement nous avons un gigantesque
défi devant nous celui de la maladie
d'alzheimer président neuf cent mille
français qui ont cette maladie qui est
un drame un drame absolu
nous avons un cancer qui est la première
cause de mortalité qui brise et qui
causent des tragédies dans toutes les
familles nous avons moitié moins de lits
de soins palliatifs vous savez pas
malheureux malades condamnés pour les
accompagner dignement vers la main il
faut de l'argent supplémentaire ou
est-ce que je vais le trouver
de tous les côtés on me dit plus pour la
recherche alzheimer plus pour la
recherche sur le cancer plus pour les
soins palliatifs ou est ce qu'on y
trouve
et la dépendance la dépendance pareil on
vit plus longtemps ou est ce qu'on les
trouve à ceux qui me disent que la
franchise c'est pas gentil
peut-être mais où est ce qu'on trouve
l'argent je le fabrique pas je veux dire
la vérité aux français
et si on veut dépenser davantage pour
notre santé il faut être capable d'avoir
la contrepartie et les recettes pour ça
dans le même temps j'ai demandé au
premier ministre d'engager une politique
déterminée qu'on n'a jamais vue en
france de lutte systématique contre la
fraude c'est un enjeu la fraude sociale
et la fraude fiscales d'environ 30
milliards par an c'est un enjeu
stratégique et je proposerai notamment
deux choses c'est que les fraudeurs aux
allocations sociales voient leurs
possibilités d'avoir ces allocations
supprimés pendant une année et les
entreprises fraudeuses aurait des
amendes plancher il faut qu'on sorte de
cette situation invraisemblable où nous
sommes un pays qu à la solidarité
généreuse mais qui n'est pas assez ferme
contre la fraude c'est l'argent du
contribuable vous nous parlez de la
croissance
la croissance à se décrète pas surtout
quand on a un baril à 80 dollars quand
on a un euro 1 dollar 40 bons même les
incantations même les meilleures
intentions ne peuvent pas faire que le
point de croissance qu'on le trouve
quand vous avez trouvé ça ne point de
croissance de 120% tout le monde dit ben
c'est vrai qu'il est volontariste mais
il exagère un peu quand même
bon ben alors qu'est ce qu'est ce qu'on
propose de rester les bras croisés
la croissance faut aller les chercher
vous êtes en train de m'expliquer tous
les deux que la croissance mondiale est
le moins grande
quel est le problème avec l'immobilier
américain les subprimes etc et donc il
faudrait mieux que nous et pourquoi il
marche et le grain de lumière
monsieur doivent d'abord moi je pense
qu'il travaille davantage que nous parce
qu'ils ont libéré les possibilités de
créer d'innover de produire de la
richesse parce que ça fait des années en
france qu'on discute savamment de la
redistribution et du partage des
richesses
moi je veux qu'on parle des conditions
de la production de richesses alors sur
la croissance 2007 du domaine pour rien
2008 officiers de la doper et 2009 ce
sera la mienne et elle fera combien bien
écouter mais il faut que nous ayons une
croissance entre 2 et demi et 3 % pour
arriver au plein emploi
je me suis engagé sur ses objectifs je
veux aller chercher cette croissance est
la seule façon d'aller chercher cette
croissance c'est ce qui est en train de
faire le gouvernement de monsieur fillon
c'est à dire de faire les réformes que
les autres ont fait avant nous pour
libérer les énergies du pays et avoir le
plein emploi
ça veut dire qu'il faut quand même
attendre deux ans pour avoir les
résultats de la politique que vous
commencez que vous initié aujourd'hui
c'est pas normal ça va commencer à nous
coûter cher et ça veut dire que pour les
déficits et bien on sera pas dans les
clous espérer 2010 plutôt 2012 qui va
pas faire plaisir à nos amis européens
permettez moi de vous dire même chapeau
que ce n'est pas exact vous venez de
m'interroger sur la franchise ce sont
des recettes vous m'avez interrogé sur
les diminutions d'effectifs dans la
fonction publique ce sont des recettes
les réformes que nous mettons colle ce
sont des recettes
je ne repars pas à la politique
d'austérité
pendant des années on a expérimenté en
france avec l'austérité vous avez moins
de dépenses et moins de recettes
je crois une politique fondée sur
l'effort sur la libération des
possibilités
travail pour le combattre et pourquoi je
demande qu'on puisse si on le veut
travailler le dimanche
parce que c'est des journées de travail
c'est des possibilités de vendre plus
céder possibilité de créer des richesses
pourquoi je me bats pour libérer les
heures supplémentaires parce que tous
les pays qui ont le plein emploi une
croissance à 3 % sont des pays qui
travaillent plus que 12 mois je ne veux
pas que les français travaillent plus
sans cette payer davantage mais c'est
quand même une drôle d'idée encore une
fois d'avoir condamné la france a tourné
le dos au travail mais les français sont
lucides ils savent parfaitement bien
quand on travaille moins que les autos
gagnent moins que les autres je veux
libérer les possibilités de travail dans
notre pays on a vu les effets immédiats
du moins en bourse de la baisse du taux
directeur de la fed la réserve fédérale
américaine ne pouvaient pas envie de
dire la même chose mais monsieur trichet
baisser votre taux au nom de la bce sans
toucher à votre indépendance
d'abord je crois à l'indépendance de la
banque centrale européenne est gelée
même voter non mais je le disais famille
fassi est extraordinaire monsieur
trichet ne peut pas dire qu'il est
indépendant et qui n'accepte pas qu'on
discute de sa politique monétaire
vous critiquez quand même donc c'est je
priais monsieur trichet qui certainement
quelqu'un de très respectable je dis
simplement regarder ce qui se passe
la banque fédérale américaine devant la
situation que nous avons de l'économie
baisse ses taux la banque centrale
obèses les baissent pas quand la banque
centrale américaine beth c'est au tour
par tour nous ne baissons pas les nôtres
on s'enfonce il ya quand même un petit
problème
j'ajoute que quand l'euro s'apprécie de
10 centimes airbus paiera milliards nous
avons un euro qui vaut pratiquement 1 41
dollar il faut faire attention
conditions de la compétitivité
moi je me bats pour que les entreprises
françaises puissent fonctionner à la
compétition mondiale
mais alors nous avons à faire face un
dumping environnemental
un dumping fiscal un dumping social et
maintenant d'un pic monétaire je dis pas
que j'ai raison je souhaite simplement
qu'on puisse discuter tout ça et enfin
je veux qu'on mette des règles dans le
capitalisme financier mondial qu'on
arrête de promouvoir les spéculateurs et
qu'on promeut les entrepreneurs
qui s'est passé dans la crise est tout à
fait scandaleuses les agences de
notation n'ont pas fait leur travail
il n'y a pas assez de transparence et
l'économie du monde n'a pas être
pénalisés par le comportement insensé de
quelques centaines de spéculateurs dans
goon est quand même entre les lignes
vous dit
en tout cas monsieur trichet baisser les
taux ça nous arrange je dis monsieur
trichet pas du tout entre les lignes
regarder ce que font les autres l'enfer
c'est pas toujours les autres et angela
merkel est d'accord avec vous sur ce
sujet à l'autre
angela merkel personne tout à fait
remarquable un partenaire et un ami
mais il ya une histoire allemande les
allemands se souviennent de l'époque où
le marque ne valait rien et où chacun
allait avec sa brouette remplie de
billets qui ne valait rien échangé à la
banque c'est une histoire qui qu'ils
étaient là nettement ce début d année
cnic exactement dans le début des années
non mais c'est à moi aussi de convaincre
de porter ce débat je ne suis pas pour
un euro faible
je dis simplement que ne pouvons pas
être la seule région du monde qui
n'utilise pas sa monnaie au service de
la croissance et de l'emploi et qui n'a
comme seule préoccupation qui n'est pas
d'inflation ce qui est très louable mais
je pense que dans la compétition
mondiale risque d'inflation est beaucoup
plus faible que celui d'une croissance
atone et celui d'un chômage trop élevé
mais que de temps en temps elle et on
dira vous agacer un peu vos partenaires
l'arrogance même parfois voilà on va
dire tiens on retrouve l'arrogance
française c'est une autre version les
plus modernes peut-être être exprimée
par nicolas sarkozy on a raison de vous
bousculer un peu madame merkel quand
vous dites qu'elle vient d'europe de
l'est de l'allemagne de l'est ont dit ah
super sympa peut-être de le dire comme
ça quand vous avez l'air de
vous indigner ou de vous inquiéter de ce
que dit les ministres des finances de
l'europe à ce qu'ils trouvent ça n'avait
pacifique ce les réformes comme celle de
l'arrogance française on ya de
l'impatience de nicolas sarkozy et la
ville haute
mais mme chabot la france pays
fondateurs de l'europe et ainsi
retrouver avec un référendum où les
français ont voté à 55% non à l'europe
vous croyez que j'ai reçu le mandat de
continuer à construire une europe qui
éloigne chaque année un peu plus des
millions de français de l'europe
vous pensez que c'est ça je devais faire
comme avant comme avant tiens que on a
voté non à la constitution de la liste
car destin 55% et je dois continuer
comme avant
la langue de bois absolue ne rien dire
attendre la france est de retour
pourquoi j'ai pris mes responsabilités
notamment sur la constitution sur le
traité simplifié le traité simplifié
nous l'avons adopté à 27 partenaires
c'est la france qui a poussé cela avait
d'ailleurs le travail remarquable
d'angela merkel mais je veux me réserver
le droit au nom des français de poser
des vrais problèmes en europe
enfin quand même l'europe n'a pas est
une passoire moi c'est très bien qu'on
commerce avec la chine mais je veux la
fin de la naïveté
pourquoi ferions nous venir des produits
chinois qui ne respectent aucune des
règles de contrainte environnementale
que par ailleurs nous imposons nos
entrepreneurs
l'europe ne doit pas être
protectionniste mais l'europe est faite
pour se protéger je me suis battue sur
la préférence communautaire
parce que je crois que c'est nécessaire
pour défendre notamment nos agriculteurs
pourquoi importer en europe des produits
qui ne respectent aucune des règles de
traçabilité que par ailleurs nous
imposons à nos éleveurs et à nos
agriculteurs mais ça mais c'est mon
devoir de le faire et j'ai le sentiment
au contraire que ce discours loin
d'agacer comme vous le dites et presse
entendu en europe
je souhaite une politique de l'énergie
je souhaite une politique de
l'immigration
je souhaite une politique de défense
commune là aussi on regarde les déficits
de la france n'ont pas la france est le
pays qui avec l'angleterre payent le
plus pour la défense de l'europe c'est
plus facile de ne pas avoir de déficit
quand son budget de la défense est égal
à zéro alors que le nôtre ces deux
portions du pipe puisque vous citez
l'immigration là et qui perd débat
actuellement avec le le projet de loi 2
brice hortefeux est ce qu'il faudra
environ un jour à des quotas par pays ou
par profession oui je le dis de façon
très claire je souhaite que nous
arrivions à établir chaque année après
un débat au parlement
un quota avec un chiffre plafond
d'étrangers que nous accueillerons sur
notre territoire
ha je souhaite également qu'à
l'intérieur de ce chiffre plafond on
réfléchisse un quota par profession par
catégorie écoutez c'est extraordinaire
savez-vous que seuls 7 % de
l'immigration d'aujourd'hui une
immigration du travail
comment s'intégrer en france si on n'a
pas de travail je souhaite porter le
chiffre de l'immigration de travail au
moins sur deux et puis naturellement à
tout appât régions du monde
tous les pays développés le font tous
les pays démocratiques le fond alors en
france dès qu'on prononce le mot
immigration immédiatement vous accuse
mais c'est invraisemblable la politique
d'immigration d'un pays c'est ce que va
devenir ce pays à 30 ans ou à 40 ans on
peut vouloir dire bah voilà nous voulons
accueillir sur notre territoire des
femmes et des hommes qui s'intégreront
je considère comme tout à fait normal
que le fait qu'on en connaisse le
français avant de venir en france c'est
quand même pas absurde
ils ont plaidé m ça vous choque comme
fadela amara exemple le test adn pour
les regroupements familiaux et le test
adn d'abord il est sur la base du
volontariat
il est destiné pour une famille qui
vient d'un pays où l'état civil n'existe
pas à pouvoir prouver que les enfants
sont bien les siens et donc à pourvoir
les regrouper en france
vous savez que ce test adn et existe
dans 11 pays en europe dont certains
socialistes comme la grande bretagne
comment se fait-il que ça ne pose aucun
problème dans ces pays et que ça fasse
débat chez nous laisser les chinois ont
dit que c'est réservé maps pour des
raisons médicales et aux français par
exemple où quand il ya des problèmes
avec la justice est là du coup certains
sont choqués on citait des membres de
votre gouvernement qui viennent de
gauche et qui dit y compris dans la
majorité d'ailleurs jugé choquant je
respecte parfaitement cette opinion si
vous me posez la question de savoir si
ça me choque réponse est non je vais
prier dans quel est votre principal
collaborateur est ce que c'est françois
fillon au clos de guerre françois fillon
premier ministre je voudrais dire
d'ailleurs un mot à propos de françois
fillon parce que vous savez souvent nous
parlons tous les jours on pense tous les
deux et on est toujours très interloqué
par les commentaires des uns les autres
françois bon nous on fait campagne
ensemble s'il ya une personne qui
connaît le projet qui est le mien c'est
françois fillon puisque nous l'avons
écrit ensemble nous avions fait campagne
ensemble et j'avais très précisément et
depuis longtemps l'idée dans la tête de
nommer françois fillon comme premier
ministre
il fait d'ailleurs son travail de façon
parfaitement remarquable et je trouve
toujours fasciné de la capacité
d'imagination sur les commentaires sur
notre relation est lui-même se montre un
peu agacé du mot collaborateur est là où
je le vois comme je le vois tous les
jours si agacement il y avait eu
j'aurais constaté certainement peut-être
même avant vous monsieur poivre d'arvor
quel est le rôle de ceux qui travaillent
avec vous à l'elysée parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya un hebdo manière cette
semaine qu'ils présentent à sa une
claude guéant disait ans l'homme le plus
puissant de france alors nul à lens
président vice présidents deux premiers
ministres deux premiers mini jeux
devraient sans doute en mettre trop
fâché voyons maintenant dans le papier
glacé schengen je vous rassure après
mais non je vous expliquais et chabot
moi j'ai toujours travaillé en équipe et
j'ai une équipe de collaborateurs assez
exceptionnel et c'est moi qui les pousse
à prendre la parole parce que je pense
qu'un collaborateur la qualité de ce que
j'ai ici doivent prendre la parole non
par la place des ministres a fortiori du
premier ministre mais pour expliquer
pourquoi j'ai fait pris tel ou tel choix
ou assumer telle ou telle décision
moi je veux pas des gens silencieux ça
ne me gêne pas que dans mon équipe
certain nombre de gens prennent la
parole j'ai voulu très peu de ministres
y en a 15 au tour du premier ministre
je trouve qu'il faut un boulot assez
remarquable alors quand on dit on pas
des espaces non plus mais bien sûr
l'espace sauf sur une chose j'attends
d'eux des résultats ils ont toute
liberté toute latitude pour voir comment
ils doivent les obtenir mais faut des
résultats
et est ce cadre à ce que le premier
ministre françois fillon et moi nous
savons une chose c'est que les français
attendent de nous quoi
des résultats je me suis engagé sur des
résultats les gens n'attendent pas de
moi que je sois ici pendant cinq ans que
rien ne bouge que je dorme
tranquillement et que je joue le
président la république
ils attendent des solutions concrètes et
des résultats
il ya une répartition des rôles entre
vous deux est ce qu'il ya un qui joue le
bon et l'autre le méchant ou l'abrupt va
je crains que vous ayez déjà répartis
des rôles à oreille parfois il en est un
que je pense déclaration j vous essayé
d'adoucir derrière francs seraient pas
chacun son tempérament on travaille main
dans la main nous sommes parfaitement
interchangeables c'est une équipe vous
savez quand je regarde la rentrée
scolaire qu'organise darcos
c'est assez remarquable ce qu'il a fait
la face on a nommé mme pécresse a
organisé l'autonomie diversité c'est
remarquable
ça fonctionne très bien nous on
travaille encore ce matin avec jean
louis borloo et nathalie kosciusko
morizet sur les états généraux de
l'environnement
c'est un choc pour l'europe entière
ce qu'on essaye de faire avec des
décisions très fortes que nous allons
annoncer notamment sur une politique
d'achats publics car je souhaite l'état
soit exemplaire en la matière non il ya
une équipe gouvernementale
placer les bons points lors de la
rentrée ce qu'elle a des mauvaises
surprises on va neiger reprise des
ventes je pense que bernard kouchner et
au ministre de faire c'est trop cher qui
fait honneur à la france et sa
déclaration sur l'iran vous a gêné non
d'abord ce qu'a fait bernard kouchner au
darfour et au liban c'est remarquable
moi je n'aurais pas employer le mot
guerre il s'en est lui même expliqué sur
l'iran c'est une affaire extrêmement
difficile l'iran essaie de se doter de
la bombe nucléaire
je les dis c'est inacceptable et je dis
aux français c'est inacceptable comment
peut-on les convaincre de renoncer à ce
projet comme la communauté
internationale a convaincu la corée du
nord et la libye à renoncer à leur
projet par la discussion par le dialogue
par les sanctions si les sanctions
actuelles ne sont pas suffisants je
souhaite des sanctions plus fortes
est ce que vous proposez aux européens
ou à la communauté internationale parce
que je serai à new york deux jours mais
c'est pas exclusive d'un dialogue avec
les iraniens
c'est une grande civilisation la société
iranienne et elle mérite mieux que ce
qu'elle connaît aujourd'hui
et quand je me bats pour qui est du
nucléaire civil dans un certain nombre
de nations arabes c'est pour bien
montrer aux iraniens que dans mon esprit
ce qui est interdit c'est nucléaire
militaire pas le nucléaire civil
quelle énergie de demain c'est une
affaire extrêmement difficile mais la
france ne veut pas de la guerre et les
déclarations de jean pierre jouyet qui
dit finalement nantes pas besoin d'un
référendum pour décider de l'entrée
éventuelle ou non de la turquie dans
l'union européenne où les reprenez votre
compte non si c'est l'avis de jean
pierre jouyet
j'aurai à faire des propositions le
moment venu dans le cas des travaux de
la la commission balladur
pour ma part c'est assez clair je ne
crois pas que la turquie ait sa place en
europe pour une raison simple c'est
qu'il est en asie mineure simplement la
turquie c'est un très grand pays
est ce que je souhaite proposer à la
turquie c'est un véritable partenariat
avec l'europe qui n'est pas une
intégration en europe
c'est d'ailleurs la proposition que j'ai
faite avec le groupe des sages pour
réfléchir à l'avenir de l'europe
il ya la question des frontières de
l'ordre on a essayé de parler des
ministres un peu de vous faire parler
des ministres on n'a pas eu tout à fait
satisfaction n'est pas donné de mauvais
points mais bon pas y passer simplement
certains annoncent déjà un remaniement
ministériel au mois de janvier alors est
ce que c'est possible et est ce que vous
souhaiter à cette occasion prolonger
encore un peu plus l'ouverture et
notamment à gauche il ya encore des
personnalités de gauche que vous pouvez
j'allais dire amener vers vous d'abord
le remaniement ministériel c'est pas
quelque chose qu'on annonce plusieurs
mois al avance ils ceux qui en ont parlé
on nous parlait imprudemment notamment
un ministre mais elle défense et l'a
évoquée en tout cas ils dépensent
charges est un mauvais temps n'ont pas
comme ça enfin je vous dis une chose ça
ne s'annonce pas comme ça alors question
beaucoup plus sérieuse c'est la sphère
de l'ouverture
moi je n'ai pas essayé de débaucher
telle ou telle personnalité
qu'est ce que j'essaie de faire de notre
chemin pour faire des grandes réformes
il faut une grande majeure
pour avoir une grande majorité il faut
rassembler les gens différents
constituer la meilleure équipe de france
possible
moi j'ai dit afin dé lahmar font un
travail remarquable à bernard kouchner à
jean pierre jouyet à jean marie bockel à
ses ministres qui ont fait le choix de
s'engager à martin hirsch qui fait un
travail extraordinaire président de
l'ancien président d'emmaüs rester
socialiste vous appliquez le projet que
j'ai défendue au moment de la
présidentielle il ya 53 % des français
qui ont voté pour moi c'est pas que des
français de droite donc il ya d'autres
socialistes comme jack lang par exemple
qui pourrait un jour rejoindre votre
équipe
des hommes comme claude allègre des
hommes comme jack lang et et d'autres
sont des hommes de qualité
je ne vois pas pourquoi je devrais
entretient un climat de guerre civile
alors que je suis élu pour cinq ans et
que je dois rassembler les français
il ya 22 millions de français qui ont
voté pour moi mais ceux qui n'ont pas
voté pour forain je suis comme un
président de la république je dois
penser un c'est pas la démocratie c'est
que celui qui est élu prend en charge la
nation dans son ensemble et ce
gouvernement avec des rachida dati rama
yade ce gouvernement qui ressemble à la
diversité de la france ce gouvernement
l'un doit rassembler et donc j'irai plus
loin dans l'ouverture chaque fois que ce
sera possible la semaine prochaine je
l'espère dominique strauss kahn peut
devenir le directeur général du fmi
alors j'aurais dû renoncer à proposer de
bleach centrale parce qu'il est
socialiste mais quelle vision sectaire
ce n'est pas la mienne pour moi
l'ouverture ce n'est pas du débauchage
c'est la constitution de grande majorité
pour faire de grandes réformes durant le
quinquennat izel droit de billetterie
sont pas d'accord par exemple avec vous
ils vous disent certains quand il ya une
décision qui est prise il dit nous
avec notre sensibilité puisqu'ils
peuvent rester socialistes ne sont pas
bien ça mais la règle qu'on s'est fixé
parce qu'on en discute tous les jours et
savez c'est un travail d'un hummer
gouvernement et françois fillon se donne
du mal on essaie d'écouter combat bon
débat notamment au conseil des ministres
et voulu des réunions beaucoup plus
libre beaucoup plus ouverte et la droite
vous cherchez pas d'accord je réfléchis
d'ailleurs à une idée peut un jour
d'ouvrir concédé brise pour que les
villageois mais pourquoi pas nouvelle
pour que les français puissent voir
comment ça n'est pas très long mais
comment mais mme chabot on a le droit à
une cuisine droit sein de voix c'est un
devoir
on débat des choses je leur dis moi la
seule chose ce que je peux pas trop juge
transiger c'est les engagements que j'ai
pris devant les français vous les
connaissiez c'est pas une nouveauté la
sphère des régimes spéciaux va pas en
discuter je vais pas demander
l'autorisation à tel ou tel des
ministres non les français ne font ils
le savaient ils ont tranché
mais pour le reste qui est une
sensibilité différente sur la question
de l'immigration sur la question des
tests adn ou sur tel ou tel autre
question mais c'est normal c'est la
fille et je ne demande pas aux ministres
de se transformer françois fillon et moi
nous les respectons dans leur diversité
fadela amara a fait une intervention n'a
dans le conseil des ministres a thing
l'andouille
elle était remarquable parce que et
c'est ce que j'ai dit à fadela reste que
tu es ne joue pas la ministre soit
ministre reste comme tu es le parcours
que fait rachida dati est exceptionnel
parce qu elle reste ce qu'elle est moi
je ne veux pas des clones je veux des
femmes et les hommes qui s'engagent
qu'ils prennent leurs responsabilités à
bras le corps qui prennent des risques
qui apporte des solutions français et
que nous soyons avec françois fillon
jugé sur les résultats
vous savez quand on se voit françois et
moi la question ponot paulin c'est pas
tel ou tel jugement tel ou tel
journaliste aussi prestigieux soit il
sait qu est-ce qui vont penser des
français à l'arrivée et ce qu'on leur a
menti
ou est ce qu'on aura tenu parole et
puisqu'on croyez moi pour moi le souci
c'est bien celui-là puisqu'on parle de
bras le corps bernard laporte
quoi qu'il arrive ce sera bien résa
d'état mais j'ai réfléchi à cette
question je j'ai proposé à bernard
laporte mauvais creed et s'offrait les
français en voilà
si on gagne un match on est plus
intelligent
si on a une paire on n'est plus rien
mais j'ai connu monsieur pas avant
d'avoir les chèques moi j'ai connu
souvent l'échec et chaque fois j'ai dû
me relever et remonter les barreaux de
l'échelle et moi je ne condamne pas les
gens parce qu'ils ont un échec parce que
je sais parfaitement que l'échec
ça fait partie de la vie donc si j'ai
proposé cette responsabilité à bernard
laporte parce que j'avais confiance dans
sa capacité
alors bon la namibie s'est bien passé
demain soir vous serez air france y en a
bien sûr naturellement
puis j'y serai comme tout le pays on
sera derrière l'équipe de france qu'il
se bat qui se bat de toutes leurs forces
qui fasse éclater leur talent qu'ils
soient heureux sur le terrain
et puis apprécier le sport c'est la vie
on gagne pas tous les jours et
d'ailleurs moi c'est les valeurs dont je
veux porter je veux dire aux français
j'ai voulu proposer une nouvelle
renaissance qu'est ce que ces carreaux
naissance
c'est une société où tout devient
possible alors qu'on en a assez de cette
société où tout est contraint tout est
figé tout et rigidifier et bien ce qui
est possible c'est de réussir puis
d'échouer
et quand vous avez échoué on vous donne
une deuxième chance je ne veux laisser
personne sur le bord de la route
quand je demande qu'on sanctionne un
chômeur qui refuseraient deux offres
raisonnables d'emploi
c'est papon pour faire le moraliste
c'est parce que je pense qu'on peut pas
vivre dans l'assistanat et je pense que
la générosité des français qui payent
des impôts
elle doit être respectée quand je
propose la fusion du service public de
l'emploi la haine politique c'est parce
que je veux qu'ils qu un seul
interlocuteur pour le chômeur c'est pas
le statut qui m'intéresse c'est la
personne parce que chacun mérite d'avoir
un emploi une affaire qui continue c'est
la faire car ce thème
dominique de villepin mis en examen se
présente aujourd'hui un peu comme une
victime à son tour et dit qu'il ya une
chose qu'il trouve absolument pas normal
c'est que une partie civile soit
aujourd'hui aussi président de la
république et avec une possibilité
d'intervention sur la justice qu'est ce
que vous lui répondez écoute c'est
extraordinaire
j'étais partie civile deux ans avant de
devenir président de la république mon
nom eût été sali on m'a fait un faux
compte avec des faux fièrement dans une
banque dont j'ignorais tout j'ai une
commission rogatoire internationale
pendant 15 mois sur le dos il a fallu
que je démontre à la justice de mon pays
qui n'avaient pas de compte c'est
commode demande à chaque français de
penser à ça un beau jour le juge il ya
vous dire monsieur vous avez un compte
dans une banque et vous devez prouver
que vous n'aviez pas le truc c'est
commode
deux ans après je deviens président de
la république et parce que je deviens
président de la république je veux dire
bon écoutez excusez moi je me suis
trompé
ce compte s'était peut-être à moi non 20
barbie de retirer votre plainte mais je
sais pas une plante en tant que
président de la république
c'est une plante bien avant que je sois
président la république je veux savoir
comment mon nom s'est trouvée sur le
fichier d'une banque dont j'ignorais
tout c'est quand même quelque chose
alors moi je ne sais pas ce que dit
monsieur villepin qu'il s'explique
devant la justice moi je veux simplement
savoir pourquoi comme 893 personnes
je me suis retrouvé titulaire d'un
compte dans une banque où j'ai jamais
mis les pieds
ça s'appelle la justice le président de
la république il est pas au dessus des
lois
philippe en dessous non plus et tout
juste quatre mois avec arlette chabot ne
nous retrouvions en votre compagnie mais
aussi en celle de ségolène royal s'était
fameux débat
il a arbitré par et souvenirs qu'est ce
que vous pensez de son parcours depuis
et plus généralement la situation du
parti socialiste moi je trouve que c'est
une femme courageuse et très estimable
peut-être avez-vous noté que pendant les
mois de campagne
je n'ai jamais attaqué parce que c'est
pas ma conception des rapports humains
et je trouve que parfois les attaques
contre elle sont un peu déplacé nature
la piste gelée qualifierais pas mais je
ne comprend pas quelque chose dans la
vie politique la concurrence c'est
normal et que celui qui veut être
président de la république vous celle de
rio pays démontre qu'il est ou quelle
est la meilleure mais pour démontrer
qu'on est le meilleur il faut parler de
ses projets et pas vouloir démolir les
autres et pareil dans les familles
politiques
je trouve ça un peu triste cela dit vous
n'êtes pas mécontent d'avoir fait un
peut imploser le parti socialiste qui a
des difficultés pour l'instant alors
vous leur avez rendu service en le
débarrassant d'un certain nombre
d'éléphants
moi je vous savez même mon but n'était
pas de les faire imploser
je les ai d'ailleurs dit à françois
bayrou et à tous les républicains
j'étais prêt à travailler avec tout le
monde c'était mon devoir une fois élu
président la république vous n'êtes plus
l'homme d'un clan les principaux
problèmes que juste avec mes propos amis
qui pensaient que parce que j'avais été
élu et parce que j'étais leur avis il
fallait que je constitue un gouvernement
qu'avec mes amis c'était pas ma
conception du chef de l'état un
président de la république ne pas d'amis
il peut garder ses sentiments pour lui
mais constitue pas un gouvernement
sur le seul critère de l'amitié parce
que ça c'est une secte
c'est un clan je ne veux pas d'état même
p je ne veux pas de nominations de
complaisance
je ne veux pas être prisonnier d'un clan
voilà pourquoi d'ailleurs il françois
fillon s'entend si bien c'est qu'on est
exactement sur la même ligne je prends
mes responsabilités mais parfois je lis
à que j'en fais trop qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent
hyper président oui je suppose que ça
veut dire et j'étais inattaquable on
vous entend partout on voit par lots
j'étais ni pourquoi ni vers la sienne
même d'ailleurs à bon pour faire la
sieste je devrais dire habitations j'ai
le temps moi je ne pense pas ça je pense
que les français attendent depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps et que justement
s'ils m'ont fait confiance
les français m'ont fait plus beau cadeau
qui soit faire confiance
on décompte que ça représente ils ont
voté à 85%
sir confiance donné sa confiance nous
ont fait confiance pour quoi pour être
un président différent pour assumer une
rupture mais j'essaye de m'engager
là on me dit aussi à vous prenez des
risques monsieur sy a des ennuis
bien sûr que les ennuis prendre des
risques mission ne pas prendre des
risques on n'est pas président de la
république
vous croyez que je vais à la télévision
en disant aux côtés excusez-moi la
réforme des régimes spéciaux c'est pas
moi c'était mon premier ministre ah oui
mais c'est vous qui le nobel premier
ministre quand je vais me cacher
derrière lui ont fait une équipe
on y va ensemble et ma conception d'un
chef d'equipe c'est d'être devant pas
derrière c'est oui de prendre plus de
risques que les autres parce qu'il est
au sommet de l'échelle pas d'en prendre
- et c'est ma façon de faire
je comprends que ça hilton n'en fait
écouter dont le système des valeurs
démocratiques c'est quand même celui qui
est élu qui doit assumer ses
responsabilités envers épouse cécilia
souhaite ne pas témoigner devant la
commission d'enquêté de l'assemblée
nationale sur la sphère des infirmières
bulgares et du médecin palestinien
devenu bulgare depuis il elle vise à
demander conseils auparavant je sais pas
elle elle aurait plutôt souhaité c'est
moi j'ai considéré que si quelqu'un
écoute et elle a fait un travail
absolument remarquable
ces malheureuses infirmières il a fallu
aller chercher ça faisait huit ans et
demi huit ans et demi qu'elle souffrait
prisonnière qu'elle était ici j ai fait
un travail absolument remarquable en la
matière j'ai estimé qu'avec le travail
qu'elle avait fait si quelqu'un avait à
rendre compte
c'était plutôt moins qu'il avait envoyé
plus tôt qu'elle ou claude guéant était
aussi sur place ou claude guerre vous
croyez que je vais me cacher vous croyez
que gérer c'est s'exposer
ce n'est pas ma conception des choses je
suis responsable c'est moi qui assume
et pour tout dire j'ai trouvé certaines
attaques n'était pas à l'honneur de ceux
qui attaquent et vous trouvez que d'une
manière générale la presse par exemple
certains s'intéressent trop à elles en
font trop sur elle je rien à dire de
plus je joue je connais la cruauté du
monde et de la vie publique c'est tout
mais sur la question que m'a posé
monsieur propre père faure si un
responsable
c'est pas l'émissaire c'est celui qui
envoie l'émissaire donc c'est à moi d'en
rendre compte
et c'est à moi de me l'expliquer quant
au secrétaire général de l'elysée qui a
fait un travail tout à fait remarquable
lui aussi il sera parfaitement à même de
donner toutes les explications
d'ailleurs si c'était si facile de
sortir ces malheureuses d'infirmières je
me demande bien pourquoi ceux qui
étaient aux affaires
à ce moment là ne l'ont pas fait c'est
une dernière question ce qui me concerne
à vous poser aujourd'hui commence la
breizh touch tm la bretagne à paris
est ce que vous avez vraiment dit ce
qu'on a lu dans le livre djessane
arrestation yasmina reza est une
romancière de très grand talent mais
c'est une romancière elle a fait un
roman dont elle a inventé non je ne suis
pas sûr d'être le premier héros puisque
je pense qu'il ya une place raisonnable
non ce renom et et voilà donc je
naturellement je n'ai pas dit ce que ce
qui m'est prêtait nie toujours ne vous
l'avez pas lu ce livre
oui un jeu tout pas faire de peine à
yasmina reza quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
vraiment beaucoup de considération son
talent littéraire mais je ne lis jamais
les livres qui sont faits sur moi parce
que je n'ai rien à apprendre la distance
alors on a terminé une dernière question
on parlait tout à l'heure de l'hyper
président
beaucoup se dit deux choses les français
lisent il va vraiment tenir le coup
comme ça pendant cinq ans comment il va
faire
et puis deuxièmement à votre avis on a
évoqué beaucoup de mesures avec la
calendrier précis à votre avis en
combien de temps vraiment les gens
pourront se dit ah les français pourront
se dire tiens on commence à sentir les
effets de la présidence de nicolas
sarkozy
et pour vous aussi vous fixez quel délai
donc vous tenez coûts et dans quelle
déjà sable ça a vraiment bougé je tiens
le coup c'est pas moi vous demandez aux
au bon dieu il faut je tiens le coup moi
j'essaie d'avoir la villa plus régler la
plus tranquille
au fond la plus banale je travaille
beaucoup mais j'ai je m'impose un
certain nombre de règles
la passion me porte aussi c'est un
honneur immense
j'ai été élu à ma première candidature
52 ans j'ai pas le droit de dire que je
suis fatigué
c'est quelque chose qui n'existe pas
pour un chef de l'état digne de ce nom
je dois porter incarner ce pays alors à
partir de quand ils verront les français
que ça a changé mais moi j'ai
l'impression qu'il pense que ça a changé
gardez les peines planchers disait que
c'était impossible il ya soixante deux
juridictions qui ont prononcé des peines
l'autre jour au tribunal de nice un
multirécidiviste 18 fois qu'ils
attaquaient des automobilistes pour
voler la à l'arraché 18 fois relâchées
eh bien depuis les peines plancher ils
ont pris trois ans de prison ferme
voilà un résultat ça changeait alors le
traité simplifié l'autonomie des
universités gaz de france suez énergie
la suppression de l'impôt sur les
successions les heures supplémentaires
qui sont détaxés la possibilité de
déduire 3000 euros la première année
d'intérêts d'emprunt ça a déjà changé
mais je souhaite que ça change encore
beaucoup plus été 2008 trois enfants à
votre avis en deuxième mi-temps sera
j'ai commencé à travailler à la première
minute
je travaillerai jusqu'à la dernière
minute et puis après chacun dira ce
qu'il en pensait la mémoire est le
deuxième mandat
tout ça je prend aucun engagement j'ai
un mandat à faire je le ferai
le mieux possible et je vous garantis
que dans mon esprit c'est vraiment ce
qui nous motive
je ne mets absolument pas dans l'idée ou
dans la perspective d'une quelconque
réélection je veux faire je veux agir et
je sais parfaitement que l'énergie que
l'on met à dure et on la met plus à
faire et croyez bien que ces cinq années
que j'ai devant moi et sont bien lourde
est bien difficile
je vais je donnerai tout pour être à
l'auteur la confiance que les gens m'ont
fait et où c'est mieux comme ça
je m'engage totalement je ne suis pas un
tricheur
je m'engage totalement et les français
le centre parfaitement
alors viendra des moments difficiles il
y aura des moments de doute il y aura
des moments complexe on est dans un
moment important dans l'histoire de
notre pays
on engage un mouvement de réformes sans
doute comme jamais depuis la libération
mais j'étais venu pour ça je suis serein
je veux le faire
puis après chacun jugera est-ce que ça a
été utile bien ou pas et les français
décideront au moment où choisiront le
prochain président de la république
merci monsieur le président de nous
avoir reçus et puis bien sûr une bonne
soirée à tous ceux qui ont suivi cet
entretien bien tour au soir merci
votre